everyone is so preoccupied with who is
the best CS go player but maybe the real
question is when was the best CS go
player
eh
okay before we get into it I wanted to
let you all know that we at the score
Esports have an official face it clan
you can join totally for free climb the
leaderboards and win points you can play
with your friends or you can even play
with Dimitri he streams Tuesdays and
Thursdays at 2PM Eastern so if you're
looking to pug feel free to hop in you
can find the link in the description
below who is the goat is a very common
question in CS go and it can be a very
difficult one to answer do you go with
mechanical skill cultural significance
achievements every new qualifier that
you add is going to bring you to a
different conclusion and currently
there's two maybe three players that
make up the bulk of this conversation
however many of the best players to ever
touch the game didn't play at the same
level during the same eras as others so
it feels unfair to ignore 10 plus years
of competitive play right well the
official CS go face it account was
thinking the exact same thing because
just the other day they posed this
question who is the scariest player in
their Prime now answering that question
will obviously take all day and I'm sure
in the comments 95 of you will still be
upset at the conclusion I come to so for
the sake of my own sanity and time I'm
just going to pluck some of the biggest
names from their list and try to make a
case for them and what better place to
start than the beginning of csgo's
competitive life when the dynamic duo of
get right and Forest owned the spotlight
the two swedes quite literally dominated
the game during this era with their now
Infamous 87-0 map win streak and get
right stood ever so slightly higher
having been named hltv's number one
player two years in a row get right was
slapping the piss out of his opponents
at basically every encounter and was the
highest rated player on his team for two
years straight now old heads for this
reason might say that get right had the
deadliest Prime but others point out
that since CS go was technically in its
competitive infancy it's hard to judge
what level get right would be at if he
was playing today okay and I would
somewhat agree listen get right is
probably the founding father of Cs go
too many and I don't want to discredit
the skill of his opponents at the time
but it's hard to ignore that caveat that
being said maybe get right was so good
that he just made everyone else look
like [__]
I'm open to that argument now as we move
out of the nip era things truly started
to open up and this is when you can
start making a case for a lot of the
other dudes on this list I mean snacks
was a rock solid monster and in flushes
Prime everyone thought he was [__]
cheating however there's one guy who
many claim to be the game's first
Superstar a guy who played so
intelligently future Pros modeled
themselves after his likeness
olofmeister all right so we take a look
there again we start to move push-up
there towards that catwalk nice native
over coming over the top they're able to
pick up one oh
kidding dismantled the reign of nip he
won two majors and is a part of three
graffitis olofmeister was infallible and
for most of 2015 he dominated almost
every single stat line so who could have
a better Prime than that well if you
asked Olaf himself Kenny s yes in a 2015
interview during his prime Olaf said
that the only player he was scared of
was Kenny ass but why would the best
player of that time be afraid of someone
who statistically speaking wasn't as
good well case in point Kenny s was the
only guy that could do [__] like this
manages to get out of these first
position picks up
goes with a quick second shot Forest is
causing oh my goodness so much damage
done here by Kenny yes another flag
found and again Kenny s Kenny s was so
good with the op for years that it's a
widely believed conspiracy that valved
nerfed the gun because of him and
although Guardian was equally as skilled
as him at the same time canias was the
one to walk away with a major and an MVP
why because he hit his shots at the
right time and he did it in style the uh
fast pushes from Titan have been called
and found out but there's Kenny s word
too and his third as well
oh my God
now in response to that face a tweet
many seem to believe that Kenneth was in
fact the deadliest player in his prime
and although I don't agree I'm not going
to argue with that against Kenny lovers
but if we're gonna be biased here I
gotta bring up cold Sarah it is in my
humble opinion that coldzera had the
scariest peak of all time
and I would love to explain why in the
span of two years cold came out of
[__] nowhere to win two majors eight
MVP awards back-to-back HL TV number one
ratings and dominated the statlines for
almost every big event before
unceremoniously crashing into the
[__] ground if that is not a scary
Peak I don't know what is and if you
want the anecdotal evidence everybody
loves so much
where do I start that could be the
Difference Maker here in this round
Dennis is spamming up through the bench
leaving colder in a one and four there's
the first looking for a second he
connects it already gets a third as well
surely he's not gonna pull this one oh
God the man the Mist the Beast so that
answers it right Prime cold zero was the
greatest of all time thank you Devin for
enlightening us we love you so much
you're correct
not quite yes although I feel like 2016
2017 cold was the scariest Peak and
others may feel like it's Kenny pre-nerf
there is a right answer and not
everyone's gonna love it I know you were
all getting very tired of me saying this
word but statistically speaking 2021
simple is the highest peak in CS go
history and even after his phenomenal
performance this year I don't think
zaibu can top it from Impact rating to
multi-kill rounds to overall damage
output simple was him in 2021. his
performance that year one of his major
and solidified him as player of the
decade it might not be the fun or spicy
answer but it's probably the correct one
with that said I really want to hear
from you guys did simple in fact have
the highest peak of all time or do hltv
stat lines only tell half the story more
importantly someone in the comments
please let me know why it's actually
Nico and how I'm a big [__] idiot for
not bringing him up
cheers
everyone thinks that me and Dimitri hate
Nico and I don't I think he's a
fantastic player mechanically a God but
I didn't include him for the same reason
I didn't include like zanteras or twists
like they are mechanically extremely
skilled players but they were never the
best player in the world every person I
brought up was the best player in the
world at some point Nico unfortunately
was just never the best player in the
world in my opinion